who these bells were already a bad idea
audio-wise that's gonna be real bad if
anyone ever uses that phrase oh I'll be
there with bells on to say that they're
like excited to show up for something
tell them to directly off this is the
look today let's all take a collective
inhale exhale and get over it
uh-oh she's a SAS factory today hi guys
my name is grace Helbig if you didn't
know now you know your life is different
now
it's Friday we made it teach you I have
do you feel things me too I went on
Twitter and I asked you guys what kind
of video you want to see today a lot of
you said some sorta like DIY Christmas
Christmas sweater decoration type of
thing and then other people said
stream-of-consciousness video so I'm
combining both of them I'm di whining an
ugly Christmas sweater while streaming
consciousness at you are you ready for
this good Nana Nana Nana Nana and then I
got song because it asks a question but
has no interest in your answer that's
like what I do here so ugly Christmas
sweaters are thing how why there are
bigger questions that I should be asking
how and why to then ugly Christmas
sweaters ugly Christmas sweaters our
thing I accept that
I've never did I wide an ugly Christmas
sweater before but it seems fairly
straightforward what you need is a
sweater and you need a bunch of [ __ ] to
decorate it with and the rest is up to
you so I'm gonna try and DIY the ugliest
Christmas sweater I can imagine all at
the same time consciously streaming
thoughts at you CAD I don't think I can
do two things at once
sometimes I breathe and walk I lied okay
why is this weather all static and it no
sweaters could get static right okay
okay great what am i doing I'm I'm
attaching this sweater like it's pizza
dough just lay out your phone
and start decorating I'm gonna use a hot
glue gun hey how are you guys how was
your world how is your life how are
things and how are stuff see that was me
doing my impression of that song y'all
ready for this Danna I don't care to
know your answer I do huh yeah I'm
adding bells because I'm dumbass what's
happening in the world this is where now
we look up stuff that's happening in the
world right here in Rehan I get HIV
tests together in Barbados I know that
there's a bigger reason that they did
that but I don't want to know I just
want to live with that headline for a
second into it I made myself steak and
potatoes last night because I've run out
of things to do that make me seem
interesting the steak was not good and
the potatoes were very mediocre if not
below average and that has been
thrilling life update with grace Helbig
thank you for your participation are you
guys doing anything exciting for the
holidays why was that set in such a sad
tone himself I don't know self you need
to stop this conversation with ourselves
we have company how was your
Thanksgiving only people from the United
States I'm going through a real melissa
etheridge moment right now that's it no
follow-up questions oh I did not ration
these bells appropriately what's your
favorite holiday song mine's oh come all
ye faithful because that sexual fool
which toe do you prefer missile or camel
uh I put the bell to my finger how I
glued to my fingers oh oh I just how man
sports right guys can you believe it's
December already that was my impression
of a conversation you don't want to be a
part of I used to fall my bills do I
have any more bills so here's the bad
news I'm out of bells we can make this
work this is like a fun activity to do
with um like your friends or just like
people you don't trust to be fun to hang
out with without an activity ball what
do you guys want for Christmas so I
realized today I haven't drank water in
like two weeks okay so far this is look
great it's kind of she ugly Christmas
sweaters are like Liam Neeson like you
just can't come up why is it smell like
farts in here and I know that I did not
fart you can't tell but I am shaming my
dog with my eyes right now
the moon's been pretty cool lately
that's my impression of someone that's
just out of conversation topics on the
first date I papi because I have puffy
paint because I am a domestic desperate
goddess oh okay wait let's do one day
nighttime puffy pink first and then
we're gonna look up what national
holidays it is cuz that's what favorite
thing to look up with you guys anyone do
anything really embarrassing lately good
talk y'all while our puffy paint drives
a bit I am going to look up what
national holidays it is I don't like my
sweater oh this weekend the third
national roof over your head day that
makes you want to praise the roof IV
mately hate myself oh [ __ ] get your
plans ready for Monday because Monday is
bathtub party day what I'm gonna go to
the other holiday website just to
confirm these holidays okay Saturday
third roof over your head day it's
confirmed and Monday is confirmed in his
bathtub party day we'll get ready for
Monday's video because we're having a
bathtub party send me your suggestions
in the comments of how we can celebrate
bathtub party day is BPD baby well this
has been it for the street of
consciousness sorry the stream is a
little dry today but my ugly Christmas
sweater is done and I want to show it
off to you guys
tada if this isn't the ugliest Christmas
sweater you've ever seen I don't know
what you've seen happy holidays
everybody if you make an ugly Christmas
sweater tweet me the photo of it I'd be
curious
see how ugly your Christmas sweaters can
get thank you guys for watching this
video if you liked it all give it a
thumbs up leave a comment down below on
what we should do to celebrate bathtub
party day on Monday and hit this button
right here subscribe to this YouTube
channel because art like this doesn't
happen every day and I've never made
myself an ugly Christmas sweater that I
can recall though I forget everything I
do in life immediately when it's over
thank God I have a library of narcissism
to go back and watch